Das ist meine erste Reise in die Antarktis.
Das erste Mal, dass ich an einer Expedition
teilnehmen kann.
Ja, dass wird meine zweite Expedition in Antarktis
sein.
Und ich bin total gespannt wie das im Vergleich
zu der ersten Expedition sein wird.
Auf der Reise dabei haben wir sogenannte Salz-
und Lichtharfen.
Mit denen man das entstehen und schmelzen
von Eisschollen messen kann.
Es geht um Meeresuntersuchungen.
Und ich bin sehr gespannt, was uns da erwartet.
Zum einen ist es natürlich sehr kalt.
Dann sind wir auf dem offenen Meer unterwegs.
Auf dem Forschungsschiff Polarstern.
Und ich bin gespannt, wie es ist, unter solchen
Bedingungen zu forschen.
Als Mathematikerin bin ich es natürlich gewohnt
eher mit Papier und Bleistift zu arbeiten,
Theorien herzuleiten, Formeln herzuleiten.
Oder mit numerischen Computersimulationen
zu arbeiten.
In meinem Mathematikstudium hätte ich das
nicht erwartet, dass ich irgendwann in der
Antarktis stehen werde.
Und in sofern ist das für mich was ganz besonderes.
Sozusagen Hands on der Antarktis selbst Daten
zu erheben.
Und einen ganz kleinen Beitrag dazu zu machen,
dass diese großen Datenmengen, die wir sonst
immer in unseren Modellen benutzen, auch wirklich
zustande kommen.
Das ist das erste Mal, dass ich in der Antarktis
bin.
Das heißt, ich freue mich total darauf, dann
tatsächlich mal auf dem Eis dort stehen zu
können.
Was uns besonders interessiert, ist das Leben
und Sterben der Eisschollen.
Was wir messen wollen, ist letztendlich, wie
sich die Temperatur, die Salinität und auch
die Eisdicke über die Zeit verändern.
Und wir werden versuchen, mit sogenannten
Salz- und Lichtharfen, die neu entwickelt
wurden, zum ersten Mal aufzuzeichnen, wie
wirklich die Schollen wachsen und auch wieder schmelzen.